man the browns cowboys game is one that
just felt like it should have been in
prime time the browns acted like it was
the cowboys acted like it didn't
browns win 49-38 at one point though it
was statement game it was 85 bears going
into dallas and winning 44-0 kind of
statement game if anyone remembers that
i remember what a stunner that was that
was front page cover of sports
illustrated stunner and when i saw 41 to
14 i thought what in the hell is wrong
with the cowboys and what in the hell is
right with the browns now the browns
held off the assault from the cowboys
they still got the big win they hang 49
on dallas
what is the headline of this that the
cowboys stink at one and three or that
the browns after losing week one have
won three in a row i think more that the
browns have won three in a row i mean
especially with the browns we're talking
about this has been the the gutter team
of football for you know the better part
of two decades so the fact that they're
three in one even though
dallas being one and three with that
much talent on their roster and all that
stuff or at least on the offensive side
of the ball is shocking i still think
the bigger story is cleveland too and
especially the way they did it right
mike i mean to me that was kind of
a different way of fun to watch a
football game it was like star power
explosive plays with like grittiness it
wasn't like dallas where it's this high
flying we're gonna throw it all over the
place it was you know nick chubb run
reverse past jarvis landry odell beckham
jr reverses and things like that to
where not the way we always see your
receivers are like that get the ball in
their hands that way but nonetheless
they got it in their hands and
i mean come on 300 yards that's like
that's old school oklahoma nebraska
wishbone stuff when you're talking about
the run game on a defense like that
and and it really is amazing that they
were able to run the ball as well as
they could even after nick chubb exited
the game he had 43 yards the browns
finished with 307
rushing yards the browns are awaiting
news today on nick chubb's mri they were
cautiously optimistic that the knee
isn't seriously injured but the mri as
always tells the story here's baker
mayfield his stats aren't through the
roof but the team is winning and there's
a vibe in cleveland that definitely
wasn't there during the ill-fated freddy
kitchens era
we can score points uh when we need to i
think you know like we keep saying
establishing that run game
you know creating one-on-ones on the
outside in the play-action game
and then when we need to throw it we
just got to be efficient on some of
those third downs uh i thought we could
have been a little bit better i could
have been a little bit better um you
know distributing the blog finding
completions but
we're learning that we're efficient when
we need to be uh and we just have to you
know be more consistent i think that's
the biggest takeaway from today yeah we
scored a lot of points but we left a lot
out there and i truly believe that
boy if they left a lot out there and
they scored 49 that's a scary thought of
what may happen in the future but it was
clicking it was clicking without nick
chubb it was clicking with kareem hunt
who had a groin injury who didn't
contribute as much as expected
and one of the reasons it clicked and
we'll talk about this more later in the
program when we empty the notebook
because i had a conversation with kevin
stefanski the coach of the team after
the game it was clicking because of
odell beckham jr they have found a sweet
spot they found a way to make it work
and beckham ended up being a supplement
in the running game
and part of that was because chubb was
injured chris yeah well i and it's i
mean perfect i mean and i give kevin
stefanski a guy who i questions his
offense a little with this hire
i mean he's found the right formula and
way to use these guys and yeah okay the
passing game is not clicking all the
time as we've seen
nobody cares you don't make plays you
got to explosive playmakers on the
offensive side of the ball and that's
where stefanski's upped his game big
time to me i mean he's taking a little
bit of a page out of the mcvay shanahan
playbook to a degree yeah okay we're
gonna focus our offense through the run
game and then i got two guys on the edge
of my offense who when i give them the
ball they can keep you honest and keep
you off the off my run game from over
playing it with reverses to jarvis
landry and odell beckham jr but you know
quite honestly they can make
you know game-changing difference making
plays that that's the big thing and
that's really what came through for the
browns yesterday is is their big players
the ballers jarvis landry great
touchdown pass baker plays solid odell
was a superstar miles garrett gets a
strip sack fumble you know great great
roster
um you know what do i want to say depth
or planning there oh yeah we're going to
run the football we're going to be a
good running football team all right
well if you're going to do that you
better have more than one running back
in case one guy goes down oh well we got
this kid johnson and kareem hunt and wow
we didn't miss a beat really when they
went out so there was a lot there's a
lot of things i think to respect about
the browns right now the roster the
talent and then what's the fanski's
doing i think is the perfect way
for this football team to succeed and
that's why they're kind of fun and
explosive to watch right now
yeah ernest johnson had nearly a hundred
rushing yards and he's the guy that most
people would say who the hell is that
that's what i said and chubb right yeah
i did it too i thought it was hunting
chubb all year long chub goes out and
again the browns don't miss a beat it's
amazing to have over 300 rushing yards
when the top guy one of the best running
backs in the nfl leaves early with only
43. and odell
yeah this is one of those chris yeah
more than anything else i want to be
right i want to be right with the things
i report i want to be right with the
things that i predict
and i had this kind of weird feeling
that ricocheted through my torso and
disappeared yesterday or last week when
we were thinking about these games and
i'm thinking it's dallas
obj going back to texas yeah going back
against the team that he had that big
catch against
miles garrett going back home it's baker
mayfield going back to texas they only
play there the browns do once every
eight years there's an element to this
for them that makes it more special than
it does for the team that plays eight
games there every year the browns are
gonna bring it and then the thought
disappeared and i didn't act on it but
but odell beckham jr was
incredible and uh
if he plays like that every week and
there's no guarantee that he will the
challenge is
on the weeks where he's not getting the
opportunities
if they lose will that be the talking
point they need to find a balance where
he's involved and if they're winning it
doesn't matter
but in a game where they lose and he's
not involved that's where these issues
could come back to the forefront but it
based on how awkward week one was the
fact that everything with him is
stabilized that's a testament to what
kevin stefanski has done too i i think
so you're right i mean mike i think we
were both in the same camp or we're
going like man is this going to work is
odell and cleveland going to work or was
that just a you know a bad trade
you know and then cleveland's gonna be
putting him on the trade block here at
some point before the season's over i
think we were both kind of like thinking
i think this is where this is going in
cleveland
but again stefanski's found a way to
include him in the offense
and yeah he's not going to lead football
and receiving or receptions this year
and challenge you know guys like michael
thomas and deandre hopkins not going to
happen
but i think they could be a really fun
explosive team and odell could be really
happy
if you carve out that debo samuel type
role we saw for the 49ers last year gets
a handful of carries every game gets a
handful of screen passes thrown his way
every game and then of course has the
traditional route running down field off
of play action and all those type of
things too but i think what skovansky
stefanski's doing by building this team
through the run game though he's got a
chance to do that to where they're going
to win football games yeah it might not
be all past yards but all the stars he's
found ways to get them to touch the
football and feel happy and included and
look what i'm doing for the football
team and i think at the end of the day
that's what any good football player
wants to do and i just want a chance to
make a difference get the ball in my
hand i don't think odell will care if
it's through the air or on the ground
there's a balance there as well and the
guy who always comes to mind for me is
randy moss when the vikings tried under
mike tys to implement the randy ratio
which was a mistake if we can get in the
ball 40 percent of the time we'll win
games because when they look back at the
games they won hey he got the ball 40
percent of the time it doesn't work that
way you can't force it and i felt like
they were trying to force it to odell
beckham jr the other side of it is
finding ways to get the ball in his
hands because good coaches can do that
it's one thing to say we sent him on a
go route and he was triple covered and
he wasn't open and we you know what do
we do it's another thing to say we're
bringing him in motion we're giving him
a jet sweep we're giving him a handoff
we're finding ways that we get him the
ball where they can't stop us from
getting in the ball and that's something
stevansky told me after the game
yesterday he's challenging himself
to get the ball into oda for him
early early and that was the key with
randy moss get him involved early if you
didn't get randy moss involved early in
the game he checked out and i think
although beckham jr to a certain extent
will do the same thing so just get him
the ball early yeah find ways to get him
the ball early if he can run like he
ran at the end of the game
yesterday when he it should have been as
you said last night a 20-yard loss and
he ends up scoring a freaking touchdown
right
i'd hand him the ball as much as i
handed to anybody else on the team no no
no doubt and you know again i think the
big thing is too you you keep people off
your bread and butter part of your
offense right the meat and potatoes oh
you want to overplay our pulling guard
you know run to the right with nick
chubb that's gashing you and always have
the backside linebacker and the safety
down there cheating well that's where
the guys like odell beckham jr to what
you're saying mike you get them the ball
in their hands early on in the game gets
them feeling good get some juices going
maybe they make a play to jump start
your offense but at the very least they
work as a decoy to be
whoa okay there he there's that guy they
got a plan to give him the ball and the
defense is always gonna be looking for
him for the rest of the day if you give
them that those touches early on let
alone it'll stop them from overplaying
some of your real plays because they
might see that pulling guard nick chubb
run and go wait is this going to be the
reverse off of it i see odell coming in
motion and it really can help your
offense that way it doesn't have to be
complicated and stefanski seems like
he's figuring it out like i said i've
been very impressed with what i've seen
so far
meanwhile the cowboys are one and three
and there's an important dynamic that
unfolds during every dallas cowboys game
jason garrett's name trends on twitter
because cowboys fans are having sellers
remorse
we should have kept oh mr clapper
in dallas instead it's mike mccarthy and
they should be owen for but for pulling
the rabbit out of the hat or elsewhere a
couple of weeks ago against the falcons
they would be owen four here's mike
mccarthy who is already getting upset
about his new team
it ultimately falls at my feet it's my
responsibility we're not the application
of details did not exist
today
in certain spots of the game you know
there was a lot of good football that
will totally go unrecognized
that's what happens when you lose but
what i don't like is i don't like the
pattern
of the four games that we've played the
points are outrageous uh the time
possession is totally lopsided and we're
minus minus seven in a turnover ratio
and that's that's not a winning formula
no it's not a winning formula at all
that's why they've only won one game and
frankly shouldn't have won that game the
good news is dak prescott is performing
like a quarterback never has set a
record for yardage in consecutive games
but you know what when that's all your
offense has when you can't run the ball
or when you're consistently behind
that's right double digits i mean that's
the problem every game for the cowboys
is let's see how deep we can dig the
hole and then whether or not we can
frantically climb our way out of it yeah
well there's a there's a lot to discuss
here with the dallas cowboys there
really is and that's the first thing
you're right
not get yourself in a hole to where you
got to climb out of it okay well you
know who do they got to blame for that
last night dak prescott zeke elliott a
game planner who doesn't protect a right
tackle going against miles garrett who's
one of the best
pass rushers in the game you know those
two possessions were the difference of
the game they were in the shootout it
was the x's and the o's i said it would
work you're right they drew it up and
they said man this guy that's never been
drafted a right tackle we think he could
drive we we oh oh look at that line oh
he blocked the number one pick in the
draft look at that except when it's for
real and it wasn't for real i mean it
was for real but that was the difference
right there mike those two plays
you know ezekiel elliott dak prescott
two plays in a row fumble lead to short
touchdown drives for the cleveland
browns gave them that 2814 lead so they
can blame themselves for that for sure
and then i mean from what mike
mccarthy's saying and everything there
you know time of possession those days
are over for the dallas cowboys they
can't run and dominate the line of
scrimmage like the old days they're a
passing team it's done ezekiel is really
good but they're not going to be able to
do that anymore and then defense defense
defense do they play it
i mean defensively it's embarrassing
right now it really is there's nothing
other than aldon smith to look at and be
impressed by
and then also i think the thing that
jumps out to me mike with their defense
is
you know yeah there's demarcus lawrence
if you're watching on tv i mean where's
he been i mean we never say his name
anymore they're paying them a hundred
million dollars that's concerning but
they have a team that's built to play
a 4-3 defense that seattle scheme and
they hired a guy like mike nolan where
that's not really his defense and you're
seeing right now a team when the players
don't fit the scheme let alone the
players aren't that talented to begin
with or maybe not as talented as we all
thought and it's just the perfect mesh
of just get gashed on a weekly basis
right now i mean it's embarrassing what
they're doing
said lawrence after the game according
to the athletic we've got to hold
ourselves to a higher standard we've got
to play together as one i don't feel
like we're holding ourselves accountable
including myself so i call the bleep
soft and we will get better from it i
mean those are just words though how do
you actually put it into action oh i'm
going to hold myself more accountable
well if you're overmatched it doesn't
matter you're just holding yourself more
accountable for something you ultimately
can't control no i i mean you're right
yeah i mean okay i mean we know but what
are you gonna do i don't know where do
they where i have seen no silver lining
to go
well they do have this or
this group of guys is hurt and gonna be
back i mean i know they're missing some
middle linebackers but i don't look at
that and just go oh well the defense
will be fixed and good it doesn't matter
their defensive line can't get can't
rush the passer they get moved off the
ball in the
in the run game and then
secondary wise i mean we're seeing big
plays every week i mean they're
basically playing right now
we're gonna get the ball last dak
prescott we're just hoping he's gonna
score that's that's how they're playing
they're gonna get it doesn't look like
it's gonna change and right now three
games in a row the offense has made
mistakes that has hurt them in these
shootouts and they can't afford to do
that because there's no wiggle room on
their team right now
the good news for the dallas cowboys if
there is any other than dak prescott's
performance because he really
has been spectacular although part of
it's on him when you get into a
potential shootout remember the talk
last week about is it going to be a
shootout well at 1414 it looked like a
shootout was starting and then the next
thing you know it's 41-14 so at some
point along the way
dak prescott's not living up to his end
of the bargain yeah to answer what the
browns are doing chris i i think that's
you know i mean i don't want to say
that's fair because they're they're
asking so much of him right now that's
where it's just there's too much on him
every every play every drive it's just
you gotta make the perfect throw we
we're never gonna stop the other team
you gotta go down and score and when you
have to play like that like your your
hair is on fire all the time
it's gonna lead to right tackles being
on an island against miles garrett and
mistakes and things like that but yes i
mean as awesome as he's playing right
now
you know last week it was the
interception before the half ended it
was the strip sack fumble in seattle to
start the second half
you know and then of course yesterday
the the atlanta game was a bunch of
turnovers by dak prescott and ezekiel
elliott they were fortunate to come back
yes but you know again some of their
star powers and those guys on the
offensive side of the ball are letting
them down by making those mistakes and
games that yeah they're going to have to
kind of play perfect and win a shootout
so chris the record for passing yardage
in a single season
5477 set by peyton manning in 2013 just
two years after drew brees had five four
seven six yeah peyton manning
leapfrogged him by 36 inches yes dak
prescott if you saw the number that was
up on the screen 1690 passing yards
through four games i had to run this
through my calculator three times
because i didn't believe the final
number he's on pace not for five four
seven eight he's on pace for six
thousand
seven hundred and sixty passing yards
it's insane now
wouldn't it be something if he sets that
record for a team that goes five and 11
and maybe wins the division
who knows who knows in the nf
six and ten first round home game in the
playoffs
i still got a problem with that i got a
problem with that and and this is a you
know
i may forget about it by the time we do
anger grievances on wednesday but
the cowboys are one and two washington's
one and two the giant are one and three
one and three oh and four for the giants
and there are the eagles at one two and
one by virtue of whatever the hell it is
they did last night to your guy kyle
shanahan they're in first place it's
unbelievable the philadelphia eagles in
first place after a ugly tie
win that game last night that i know
we'll discuss here in a little while but
if the nfc leased it's not the nfc east
this year it's the nfc lease it's very
disappointing and yeah you're right
dallas sitting here at one and three
i mean it doesn't matter and this year
doesn't i mean yeah but this is the way
they're gonna have to do it and he might
throw for six thousand yards this year
i'm like i'm dead serious i think he's
gonna get close he's gonna break the
record
with those weapons and as bad as their
defense is
it's going to lay out to where
yeah they're going to come out pressing
the issue in the past game but i just
can't imagine there's any game where
they're going to be able to be like oh
let's let's sit back we got this game
won
i just don't see how that happens with
their defense and they're going to be in
a lot of these shootouts and i would
expect them to challenge it i really
would
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports